is it saying that politics is in
everything but does that even boil down
to your morning cup of coffee a veteran
owned and operated coffee company in
Salt Lake City is calling itself the
premier brand for conservative coffee
drinkers Michelle Miller is here to tell
us how the controversial owners are
giving back to their community one batch
at a time Michelle good morning good
morning well the founder of black rifle
coffee started out in his basement with
just eighteen hundred dollars he says
fueling freedom-loving Americans helped
the company sell more than 1 million
pounds of coffee last year thanks in
part to irreverent marketing designed to
turn heads this should be it's a lighter
it's a lighter roast and you should
actually taste a little bit of almost a
lemon at the top that's what Evan Hafer
isn't your typical coffee connoisseur
he's been roasting his own special
blends for over a decade in the most
unusual places I was deploying back and
forth from places like Iraq and
Afghanistan at the time I couldn't find
a good cup of coffee what's the time you
were restricted to just what's called
chow hall or dining facility coffee
which horrible terrible it is horrible
so as a guy that truly loves coffee I
was just looking to find a great
solution to what I felt was kind of a
problem that solution black rifle coffee
mat best helped him create the company
he came to the idea with my other
business part saying hey do you guys
want to do a coffee like I don't really
know coffee but it sounds like a great
idea a former Army Ranger best it
already proved himself with the military
clothing line article 15 we have no
competitors
that's a pretty big statement Namie
another CEO that's carried a saw through
an alley at 3 o'clock in the morning in
Baghdad Iraq there isn't one to them
selling a great cup of joe meant selling
people on the culture of the company
itself it's like family community
constitutional rights and civil
liberties and community for us is the
veteran community and everybody that
does really the grind that makes America
what it is and sacrifice their own
personal life for the benefit of their
communities people ask us why we have so
many guns I just tell them how about
over 200 years of freedom these videos
have been their primary marketing tools
controversial unconventional
fresh-roasted freedom and
tongue-in-cheek we have a coffee club
which means you spend less time ordering
and more time doing what you love
no look essentially we're taking a
satirical approach to our values right
I'm a pro-gun guy but very pro-gun but
obviously it's way over the top and the
videos but it was two other moves that
put black rifle on the map last year a
plug tweeted out by Donald Trump jr.
after coffee maker Keurig pulled ads
from Sean Hannity's FoxNews show during
the Alabama Senate race he'll take it
well it's absolutely will take it in
this and this is the problem I think
that people divide too much on the left
and right of someone on you know the
political spectrum that you necessarily
don't agree with wants to put support a
cause that I'm devoting my whole entire
life to you're absolutely right I'm
gonna be very happy that he's spreading
the message and after former Starbucks
CEO Howard Schultz promised to hire
10,000 refugees on the heels of the
president's travel ban black rifle
pledged to hire 10,000 veterans he go
for one hundred plus to ten thousand
we're the fastest growing coffee company
in America franchise opportunity is
where it's going to happen
would you call yourselves political just
because of who we are we're somewhat
political there's a war on freedom right
now which is this politically correct
culture where you know you you're you're
so worried about stepping on an
offensive mind even in your own office
you can't take the men and women that
have been doing the most unpolitical e
correct act in the history of mankind
and then swing war and then swing them
in the matter of weeks back into a
corporate infrastructure and allow them
to fit in perfect and if they don't have
to order you call them a failure and
then where does that leave them homeless
jobless the dead grass rest suicidal yes
sure the statistics are coming in so we
have we have over a 50% veteran hiring
rate we have no less than probably five
conversations a week about PTSD every
day we have great conversations about
how we can be a more proactive and
responsible steward
of our subculture those conversations
they say started with the very founding
of the nation itself ODEs to service
hang everywhere in the company's Salt
Lake City headquarters dating back to
the rebels behind the Boston Tea Party
post 1773 it was seen as unpatriotic to
drink tea in America Wow so we shifted
to coffee because of the American
Revolution honoring those patriots Hafer
says means honoring immigrants like
muhammad wally taslim the Afghan
commandos served alongside some black
rifle employees on their tours we are
fighting Taliban Isis and al Qaeda for
13 years we support each other it's team
of 102 employees include 47 veterans and
30 women several of whom are senior
level executives hey first says don't
let the black hats fool you they're
waging guerrilla warfare on the coffee
establishment typical coffee culture is
funny it's a it's a funny mix of
pseudo-intellectual ism and conformity
in a way that's like very weird for us
if you go into like any of the big-name
coffee companies you know they look like
they should be chopping wood but they
don't have the calluses to prove it and
that's kind of the difference which is
will make a great cup of coffee and we
can also beat you up don't worry they
were just kidding about that last part
besides you know I could take them right
you could take them I see you Michelle
but they're really serious about this
mission they want to employ veterans
black rifle has two stores they plan to
operate or open a hundred more in the
next five years and I'll say they hope
to double the number of their employees
by next year so most importantly quickly
is the coffee good oh it's really good I
know I'm a coffee connoisseur I worry
about semi-automatic weapons and lots of
caffeine strange mix Michelle Miller
thanks